WELL, YOU MAY NOT HAVE HEARD
HER NAME BEFORE BUT UNTIL A
FEW DAYS AGO MADELINE WESTER
HOW THE WAS THE PERSONAL
ASSISTANT TO PRESIDENT
TRUMP.
BY ALL ACCOUNTS SHE WORKED
HARD AND DID THEY'RE JOB.
HARD TO FIND ANYONE IN
WASHINGTON WHO DOESN'T LIKE
HER.
NOW SHE IS UNEMPLOYED AND
HUMILIATED.
HOW DID THAT HAPPEN?
SHE MADE THE MISTAKE OF
EATING DINNER WITH A "THE
WASHINGTON POST" REPORTER
CALLED PHIL RUT RUTGER.
HE MADE CADDIE REMARKS ABOUT
THE PRESIDENT'S DAUGHTERS.
UNWISE BUT HARDLY WITHOUT
PRECEDENT.
THAT CAN HAPPEN AT DINNERS
WHERE WINE IS SERVED.
>> WHAT'S STUNNING, WHAT IS
REALLY UNUSUAL IS WHAT
HAPPENED NEXT.
THE MEAL WAS EXPLICITLY OFF
THE RECORD AND FOR
JOURNALISTS THAT IS A BRIGHT
LINE.
THAT'S THE BRIGHTEST OF ALL
INFORMATION JOURNALISTS
LEARN IN OFF-THE-RECORD
CONVERSATIONS ABSOLUTELY
CANNOT BE SHARED.
IT'S ONE OF THE FEW
UNBREAKABLE RULES OF THE
BUSINESS.
EVERYBODY IN THE BUSINESS
KNOWS THAT.
BUT BECAUSE MADELINE
WESTERHOWT WORKED FOR DONALD
TRUMP PHIL RUTGER OF "THE
WASHINGTON POST" DECIDED TO
BREAK THAT RULE, CASUALLY
BREAK IT.
ACCORDING TO MULTIPLE
SOURCES PHIL RUTGER DECIDED
TO BURN HER AND SHARE HER
REMARKS WITH OTHERS.
SHE WAS IMMEDIATELY FIRED
AND AS WE SAID HUMILIATED
HER LIFE COMPLETELY
DERAILED.
RUTGER, MEANWHILE, RETURNED
TO WASHINGTON AS A HERO.
IN FACT, HE WAS HAPPILY
YACKING AWAY ON MSNBC THIS
AFTERNOON.
HIS BOSSES AT "THE
WASHINGTON POST" ISSUED A